I stare at the stars, and the sky above, and think, what am I made of?
Am I full of sorrow?
Am I hurt and pain?
Or am I filled with love?
I walk by myself on the streets below, and ask every child I know.
Do you think tomorrow will bring sun or rain?
Which one of these will show?
I can't say goodbye to yesterday, my friend.
I keep holding on till the end.
Out of the darkness, there is no other way than the light leading to yesterday.
It's there that I'll find inner peace, not war, and dreams that I let slip away.
I will find the joyfulness I'm looking for, way back in yesterday.
Of day.
For day.
Alright,
dear, give me a grace.
And this is the second one.
Why can't each of us in the world ever see The best things in life are free Little sounds of laughter, a warm hug A smile, a kiss from you to me I fall to my knees I cry and I cry Love, do not pass me by Happy ever after Please stay for a while Make time perfume Use to fly I can't say goodbye to yesterday,
my friend Cause I know how good it has been Facing forever, here I stand Come on in, in the old In the new yesterday It's there that I'll find Inner peace, not war And dreams that I let slip away I will find the joyfulness I'm looking for Way back to yesterday
I'll see
you next time.